[Música]
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson y la presidenta de la comisión
europea a ursula von der leyen
sostendrán un encuentro en el que
decidirán si hay o no humo blanco en las
negociaciones de un acuerdo post precise
en donde superarán las discrepancias en
torno a la pesca la competencia y la
futura relación que habrá entre londres
y bruselas
hay expectativa en argentina por la
votación de mañana jueves en el congreso
por el proyecto de ley que legaliza la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo la
propuesta hecha por el presidente
alberto fernández genera discrepancias
en la sociedad argentina para la jornada
de hoy hay convocadas múltiples
manifestaciones tanto a favor como en
contra
el gobierno de francia examinará el
polémico proyecto de ley que busca poner
controles a la difusión de ideologías
islámicas extremistas el texto será
presentado al consejo de ministros
quienes deberán opinar sobre el mismo
esta revisión tiene lugar la misma fecha
del aniversario de la adopción de la ley
de 1905 sobre la separación del estado y
la iglesia francesa
muy buenas tardes américa latina'
bienvenidos a este bloque informativo en
france24 soy santiago lópez gonzález
gracias por acompañarnos a esta hora el
primer ministro del reino unido- boris
johnson y la presidenta de la comisión
europea a ursula von der leyen se
reunirán en las próximas horas en la
ciudad de bruselas en bélgica en un
encuentro del que depende si el break
city tiene lugar de manera caótica o
mediante un acuerdo
tras semanas de negociaciones las
conversaciones quedaron estancadas en
tres temas específicos la pesca en aguas
británicas normas de competencia ayudas
estatales y también la futura relación
entre londres y bruselas pese a las
discrepancias entre las partes a
expectativa por un posible acuerdo antes
del 31 de diciembre del 2020 y así
evitar el llamado pre éxito dado que
conforme al pacto de salida entre las
partes el reino unido- sale oficialmente
del bloque europeo a partir del primero
de enero 2021
sobre estas conversaciones el primer
ministro británico se refirió a ellas
antes de partir hacia bruselas
escuchemos
y tiene toda la razón en que todavía
queda mucho por hacer y espero
discutirlo con la comisionada von der
leyen esta noche
pero debo decirle a la cámara que
nuestros amigos de la unión europea
insisten en que si en un futuro aprueban
una ley una con la que nosotros no
cumplamos o no seguimos entonces tiene
el derecho automático para castigarnos y
en segundo lugar están diciendo que el
reino unido debería ser el único país
del mundo que no tiene control soberano
sobre sus aguas de pesca y no creo señor
presidente que eso sean los términos que
cualquier primer ministro de este país
debería aceptar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y previamente conversamos con luisa
pulido la corresponsal de france 24 en
londres y nos dio más detalles de este
esperado encuentro en bruselas que puede
llevar a un acuerdo entre el reino unido
y la unión europea
buenas tardes era el día de darlo todo
por el todo para que finalmente haya
humo blanco en estas negociaciones que
están estancadas en los tres puntos que
ya mencionas que pueden resumirse en la
soberanía de las partes reino unido está
optimista ha dicho que ha dado un gesto
de buena voluntad retirando las
polémicas cláusulas de irlanda del norte
de la ley del mercado interno que le
permitían le daban el poder de violar la
ley internacional y entonces romper el
acuerdo break sheet hay optimismo pero
también mucho realismo es muy difícil
llegar a un acuerdo pero lo cierto es
que alguna de las partes va a tener que
ceder será una cena la de esta noche en
bruselas boris johnson viajará esta
tarde entonces a la capital belga
y a pesar de estas conversaciones entre
londres y bruselas la posibilidad de aún
no viene entre las partes es una
realidad la falta de un pacto dejaría al
reino unido ya la unión europea con una
relación comercial plenamente sometida a
los reglamentos de la organización
mundial del comercio un escenario que
plantea entonces tarifas comerciales
controles fronterizos y aduaneros y
también la ralentización de las cadenas
de suministro así como una serie
afectación en los mercados financieros
es el fin del libre comercio entre el
reino unido y la unión europea bajo las
reglas de la oms organización mundial
del comercio las importaciones de ambos
lados del canal enfrentarían a tarifas
85% de los productos alimenticios
europeos que lleguen al reino unido
estarían sujetos a tasas del 5 por
ciento recargando potencialmente a los
supermercados británicos un sobre costos
de unos 3.000 millones de libras
esterlinas por su parte los autos
británicos enviados a la unión europea
enfrentarían tarifas de 10% por unos
5.700 millones de libras esterlinas al
año la oficina de presupuestos y
responsable
del reino unido prevee que dichas
tarifas le costarían un 2% del pib a
europa perder el libre acceso al mercado
británico le costaría cerca de 33 mil
millones de euros de ventas anuales con
una caída del 10 por ciento en
exportaciones los negocios en ambas
partes se enfrentarían a más papeleo y
controles de aduanas reino unido ha
estado luchando para construir docenas
de nuevos parques de camiones de paso de
aduanas para evitar la congestión en los
puertos simulacros recientes en
dirección a francia han resultado en
filas interminables en los pasos
fronterizos hay preocupación por el
abastecimiento de medicinas hacia el
reino unido en medio de la pandemia
aunque las autoridades indican que la
llegada de vacunas no se verá
interrumpida el sector de servicios
británicos representa el 80 por ciento
de la economía del país incluidos los
servicios financieros con cerca del 7
por ciento del pib un break sheet sin
acuerdo impediría a las firmas
británicas servir a clientes europeos
muchas ya constituyeron filiales
europeas para mantener el acceso también
significaría que las flotas de pesca
europeas perderían acceso a las aguas
británicas y viceversa amenazan
el ya precario modo de vida de las
comunidades costeras de ambos lados para
los ciudadanos el libre movimiento se
acaba al final del proceso de transición
con o sin tratado los ciudadanos
británicos perderán su derecho a vivir y
a trabajar en la unión europea a menos
que ya residan allí antes del fin del
2020 una salida caótica del reino unido-
del mercado único no es el fin nuevo
tratado podría ser negociado en
cualquier momento sin embargo muchos
observadores dicen que podrían pasar
meses en 2021 antes de reanudar los
diálogos y nos vamos a eeuu allí el
presidente de donald trump y el
mandatario electo joe biden expusieron
sus posiciones sobre la vacunación
contra el kobe 19 para su país
trump convocó a una cumbre en donde
presumió sobre los logros alcanzados en
materia de preparación para una
vacunación a gran escala en las próximas
semanas mientras que bardem aseguró que
inoculará a 100 millones de personas en
los primeros 100 días de su mandato esto
tiene lugar cuando eeuu ya superó los 15
millones de casos de contagio
y otra parte de la organización
panamericana de la salud informó que en
las últimas semanas el continente
americano ha registrado los niveles de
altos de contagio de de kobe 19 más
altos desde el inicio de la pandemia el
anuncio lo hizo carissa etienne la
directora de esta organización quien
indicó que pese a que estamos viviendo
con el coronavirus desde hace varios
meses preocupa la situación en la región
por el rápido aumento de los nuevos
casos de otra parte del gobierno de
canadá también ya dio luz verde al uso
de la vacuna desarrollada por facer y
bayern tech para ser utilizada en todo
el territorio de ese país
y alemania superó sus recortes de
fallecidos por cuenta del coronavirus al
registrar 590 muertos en solamente 24
horas números que pusieron en completa
alerta a las autoridades alemanas que
temen una saturación de los servicios de
salud después de las fiestas de fin de
año sobre este tema la canciller alemana
angela merkel afirmó estar de acuerdo
con las recomendaciones de cerrar los
establecimientos comerciales después de
navidad y hasta el 10 de enero para
evitar más contagios y fallecidos la
canciller indicó que hay mucho contacto
entre las personas y que las cifras de
contagio y muerte son completamente
inaceptables las declaraciones de la
canciller merkel son respaldadas por
científicos alemanes de renombre que se
mostraron a favor de un confinamiento
total en la que es la mayor economía de
europa
estamos viviendo en una pandemia y eso
significa que estamos viviendo en
circunstancias extraordinarias estamos
en una situación en la que estamos
enfrentando desafíos con los que
alemania no había lidiado nunca
y necesitamos responder a estas
circunstancias extraordinarias con
medidas extraordinarias y esto es lo que
hemos expresado con este presupuesto
la alta comisionada de la onu para los
derechos humanos michelle bachelet
indicó que las vacunas contra el kobe 19
por si solas no pueden resolver la
pandemia o curar el daño que ya ha
causado esta pandemia a nivel mundial
estas fueron sus palabras
es algo que no podemos hacer es volver
al día cero antes del coi 19 ese mundo
era un mundo lleno de inequidades lleno
de miseria de mucha gente había hambre
así que necesitamos un mundo que se
recupere mejor necesitamos un mundo que
tenga una economía inclusiva donde la
prosperidad sea compartida y necesitamos
un mundo más verde donde la
sostenibilidad sea esencial donde
respetemos la naturaleza y donde la
biodiversidad sea respetada porque de lo
contrario quiero decir podemos encontrar
la vacuna para el coi 19 pero tendremos
otras crisis que vendrán
este juego es el congreso de argentina
votará el proyecto de ley que legalizará
la interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
un proyecto que fue presentado por el
presidente alberto fernández para la
jornada de hoy están previstas múltiples
manifestaciones tanto a favor como en
contra de este proyecto marina sardiña
nos cuenta más
en argentina más de 3000 mujeres
fallecieron desde 1983 debido a
complicaciones por abortos inseguros
unas cifras que afectan con especial
incidencia a las mujeres en situación de
pobreza consecuencia de su penalización
ahora los pañuelos verdes y celestes
vuelven a inundar las plazas del país al
tiempo que el debate del proyecto sobre
la interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
resurge en el congreso luego de que el
presidente alberto fernández enviara un
proyecto propio al legislativo se tratan
de dos proyectos el emitido por el poder
ejecutivo y el de la campaña nacional
por el derecho al aborto legal seguro y
gratuito
ambos se estipulan el aborto voluntario
hasta la semana 14 del embarazo más allá
de ese plazo será legal en casos de
violación y riesgos de salud de la
persona gestante como ocurre desde 1921
en el ejercicio de sus derechos humanos
toda mujer u otras entidades con
capacidad de gestar tienen derecho a
decidir voluntariamente y acceder a la
interrupción de su embarazo hasta las 14
semanas inclusive del proceso
gestacional sin embargo difieren en la
cláusula de la objeción de conciencia
para los pañuelos verdes se trata de un
instrumento para no realizar la práctica
y piden que se legisle de forma que
prevalezcan los derechos de la mujer y
no del objeto por el lado celeste piden
no reconocer el aborto como un derecho
secula 2 por la iglesia católica y
evangelista y cuentan con el apoyo en el
senado donde la legalización de la
interrupción del embarazo quedó
sepultada en 2018 y cambiamos de tema el
gobierno de francia examinará el
proyecto de ley que busca restringir la
difusión de ideologías extremistas
islámicas el texto será presentado al
consejo de ministros franceses quienes
deberán dar su opinión al respecto
ahora se llama ley de defensa de los
principios republicanos la palabra
separatismo ha sido borrada del título
del texto 57 artículos que han recorrido
un largo camino desde que emanuel manjón
presentó su plan a principios de octubre
desde entonces tres atentados de
islamistas radicales han golpeado el
país como medidas principales del
proyecto en primer lugar la lucha contra
el odio en línea con la creación de un
nuevo crimen el delito de poner en
peligro la vida de otros al difundir
información privada de don johnson doy
un ejemplo público en las redes sociales
fui controlado por un policía su hija
está en tal escuela en tal ciudad se
convierte en un delito y esto antes no
existía salsa durante 1 faction está
lista para eso es lo que le pasó al
profesor asesinado se envió el patch y
cuyo nombre y dirección de la escuela
había sido publicado en facebook este
nuevo delito será castigado con tres
años de prisión y una multa de 45.000
euros la ley también prevé que se
condene la intimidación a los
funcionarios públicos aquí también se
crea un nuevo delito para aquellos que
atacan a un agente por motivos
religiosos
o ideológicos de los padres que van a
ver a un profesor para decirle deje de
enseñar caricaturas la libertad de
expresión mañana será un delito penal
el proyecto de ley también prevé el fin
de la escolarización en casa para los
niños de 3 a 16 años excepto por motivos
muy limitados así como un control
reforzado de las escuelas sin contratos
con el estado con la posibilidad de
cierre administrativo en caso de
infracciones graves y repetidas los
lugares de culto musulmanes tendrán que
ser más transparentes en términos de
contabilidad y finanzas las donaciones
extranjeras de más de diez mil euros en
particular serán sometidas a un declarar
la procedencia de esos recursos
después de permanecer meses en tierra y
extensas investigaciones el polémico
avión boeing 737 max volvió a surcar los
cielos al ser realizado el primer vuelo
con pasajeros de manera exitosa la
aerolínea brasileña gol líneas aéreas se
convirtió en la primera compañía aérea
de américa latina' en volver a poner en
servicio este tipo de avión al programar
un vuelo entre la ciudad de san pablo y
la ciudad de porto alegre en el sur del
país después de recibir la autorización
por parte de la agencia de aviación
civil de brasil el boeing 737 max fue
retirado temporalmente de operación a
nivel mundial después de registrar dos
accidentes mortales en indonesia y
etiopía
y con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias en france 24 más información en
la página web france24 puntocom también
en las redes sociales y en la app
descargando la en sus dispositivos
móviles siga con nosotros